well guys as you know I like to do new
things on my channel and one of the
things that I really would like to do is
kind of start to give you guys an idea
of what some of my all-time favorite
films are I don't have a particularly I
don't have a number one pick a lot of
people have asked me for that but I do
have a select group of films that I just
adore and I love talking about like
force love watching as well and Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world is one of them the
two things happen to me recently that
made me want to do a review for Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world number one I
watched it and I was like oh yeah this
movie is amazing but the other thing
that happened was that Michael Cera
debuted this comedy network that he's
involved with with some other stars like
Sarah Silverman on YouTube and I thought
what better way to tell you guys how I'm
enjoying that than in a review for Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world which is one of my
favorite films here's a brief little
clip of his comedy network it's called
Josh
[Music]
I let the annotation but you guys go
check that out because I've been digging
it and I hope you guys like it it has a
lot of cool actors and stars and n-space
like sketch comedy
I let the annotation for you guys to go
check that out if you would enjoy to for
me to really describe myself as a person
all I really have to do is say that this
is one of my favorite films and you know
a lot about me already Scott Pilgrim is
this loner kid he's a dork he's in a
band he plays bass and he meets this
girl Ramona played by Mary Elizabeth
Winstead and he basically falls
head-over-heels in love with her and he
follows her around everywhere and they
start hanging out and eventually he
discovers that she has evil exes
relationships she has previously had
that want to kill Scott and they
challenge him to many duels this movie
is like anime and video games combined
and when you do it right can you
honestly think of a better combination
it's directed by Edgar Wright and he
made Hot Fuzz and Shaun of the Dead also
two very good films and that's someone
who really appreciates Direction myself
that is something that I look for in my
favorite films how is the film directed
how is it pasted Edgar Wright has a way
of using his stylish direction to
enhance the story in such a cool way now
if you don't know what the movie is
about it is based off of a manga and
this is one of the best examples of
manga to film translations that I've
seen you can actually look at this film
and it looks at times like a comic book
and it feels like a manga it really does
and they did such a good job of
recreating the panel's that are actually
in the manga in this film too a
painstaking degree I mean there's even
one scene in this movie that they
actually reshot because a character
wasn't wearing socks and when they
looked at the manga the character was
wearing socks
so they reshot the entire scene to make
the character wear socks that's how
careful they were when they were making
this movie isn't that awesome
the way Edgar Wright directed this movie
was so stylish the use of colors the
many hints of things with X's in the
background you see throughout the movie
the way that the film's humor is crafted
it's all so well done and original there
really is no other film like this
Michael Cera is Michael Cera in this
movie I don't know if he's ever gonna
break out of that I'm Michael Cera and
my voice is very quiet and I make funny
little jokes quietly thing but it works
excellently in this film he's so funny
here and his action scenes are actually
really well done - yes there's a large
use of stunt doubles at times but the
scenes that he does are actually pretty
impressive the cast of this movie is
great you got jason schwartzman in there
as gideon and he's just loving every
second of this movie Chris Evans is also
in this film as one of the evil exes he
plays this very over-the-top action star
and he was also just relishing this role
it really seemed like this film gave so
many actors an opportunity to just go
for a roll and get really juicy into it
and not seem as if it was too much and I
really like that about this movie
because that's that style of manga and
anime where everything is over-the-top
the eyes are always exaggerated
everything in manga is exaggerated and
Edgar Wright and the filmmakers behind
this movie really understood that
because they took that exact same feel
and style and translated it to film
everything in this movie is big and
exaggerated and over-the-top but that's
what it's like in manga as well also the
music in this movie is fantastic there
are excellent excellent songs in this
film and the music plays just as big
apart as the visual look of the film it
really adds something to the movie and
because they're in a band and because
sometimes they actually have to fight
other people with their music it's
really cool I mean when do you ever see
stuff like that I'll never forget the
first time I saw this movie in theaters
and the universal logo pops up and it
was like super nes style with a midi
music in the background I knew that I
was about to experience something
special and ever since then Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world has been one of my
favorite films it is extremely
impressively directed it has great fight
scenes it's actually really funny and
has great supporting characters like
Kieran Culkin as his roommate I just
that guy is so great in this film and it
has this great nostalgic vibe of
videogames translated with anime it's an
original film and I still have not seen
a film like it I strongly recommend it
and it is one of my favorite movies I'm
gonna give Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
an A+
I'd like to do more reviews like this
where I mentioned my favorite films and
let you guys know some of my favorites
as I said I don't have a list or an
order of any kind I just I can't bring
myself to do that
it's way too much thinking and it
changes too often too but I do have a
group of favorites so I want to tell you
guys more about them in the future
thanks a lot as always for watching guys
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]